[Music]
on this tuesday night an enormous
explosion blasts
through beirut
the destruction the mass casualties and
the search
for the cause also tonight pandemic
prediction
canada's chief public health officer on
how much longer our new reality
could last moving beyond calorie
counting what we've done
up until this point hasn't worked the
new guidelines on treating obesity
and why it should be considered a
chronic disease
and a medical diagnosis more than 70
million years in the making
what dinosaurs and humans have in common
global national with donna friesen
the destruction is overwhelming this is
the port in lebanon's capital beirut
rubble everywhere buildings blasted open
vehicles flipped and smashed those
caught in it those who survived
dazed and bloody hospitals already
struggling to cope with kovid 19
now flooded with so many blast victims
some are being treated outside officials
say at least 78 people are known to have
died
and almost 4 000 are injured the red
cross has put out an urgent appeal for
blood donors
lebanon has a history of conflict and of
bombings
but the scale of this is like nothing
else
good evening and thanks for joining us
the massive explosion was so powerful
the shock wave was felt hundreds of
kilometers away
lebanon's internal security chief says
it happened in an area in the port that
housed
highly explosive materials the cause is
not clear yet but as crystal gomencing
reports
the damage certainly is
the massive plume of black smoke rising
up over the port
impossible to miss mixed into that smoke
flashes of light believed to be
fireworks going off
even those in cars during the evening
rush hour grabbed their phones to record
the dramatic scene
but no one was prepared for what came
next
an explosion so powerful shock waves
were reportedly felt clear across the
mediterranean
in cyprus the glass shattered all over
the car the cars around us
the buildings all the glass just went
down it was raining glass
all over the city of beirut images show
buildings far
from the explosion site destroyed many
people were caught on the roads
unsure of what to do next
lebanon's prime minister said the nation
is suffering
and called on friendly neighboring
countries for support
faced with a major economic crisis and
the strain of the covet 19 pandemic
lebanon's health system is itself ailing
and now struggling to keep up with the
thousands of injured people
caught up in the explosion
this woman says we thought it was a
container in the port that was on fire
and they weren't able to put it out
a few seconds later we were flying
through the air
exactly what happened is unknown one
security official says the source of the
blast was a building at the port
where explosive material was kept
wednesday has been declared a national
day of mourning
crystal gomencing global news london
it's not clear if there are any
canadians among the victims though we
know that nearly 11 000 canadians are
registered as being in lebanon
prime minister justin trudeau has
offered canada's support to the country
tweeting absolutely tragic news coming
out of beirut canadians are thinking of
everyone who has been injured and all
those who are trying to locate a friend
or family member
or who have lost a loved one we're
keeping you in our thoughts and we stand
ready to assist
in any way we can and canada's foreign
affairs minister tweeted
tragic news out of beirut today canada
is closely monitoring the situation
our hearts are with the victims and
their families we stand with the people
of lebanon and the diaspora during this
difficult time and we
are ready to assist however we can he
urged any canadians in need of emergency
consular assistance
to contact the government before this
explosion lebanon was already crippled
by the worst economic crisis
in years decades of political
mismanagement corruption and
overspending
have accelerated in recent months to the
point of economic collapse
the lebanese pound has lost 80 percent
of its value since last october
pandemic restrictions have led to job
losses poverty and despair
unemployment is at 32 percent many parts
of lebanon only get two or three hours
of electricity a day
bread a staple of the lebanese diet is
in short supply because the government
can't fund imports of wheat
the charity save the children estimates
more than 900 000 people living in and
around beirut
do not have enough money to buy food and
talks with the imf
about a 10 billion dollar bailout
stalled in july
shifting now to the covet 19 crisis
there's a new warning about the ripple
effects of the pandemic
the united nations says the world faces
what it calls a generational catastrophe
in education and it says countries must
make reopening schools
safely a top priority according to the
un
as of mid-july schools in more than 160
countries were closed
more than a billion students were
affected and at least 40 million
children have missed out on preschool
the u.n says it's the largest disruption
in education in modern history
and it could undermine decades of
progress
we are at a defining moment for the
world's children and young people
once local transmission of covet 19 is
under control
getting students back into schools and
learning institutions as safely as
possible must be a top priority
the world health organization is warning
russia to proceed with caution
after it announced mass production of a
covid19 vaccine will begin this fall
russia claims it's on the cusp of a
vaccine for covid19
though there are widespread reports
scientists rushed through tests and
injected themselves with the prototype
to speed up the process wh urged russia
to follow established guidelines for
safe and effective vaccine development
it says six candidates have progressed
to phase three levels of testing
the russian vaccine is still in phase
one
here at home canada's top doctor is
trying to temper expectations about a
vaccine
dr teresa tam says even if of an
effective vaccine
is developed it won't be widely
available immediately
and it won't mean a quick return to
normal as michael couture reports tam
says canadians should get used to the
idea
of living with restrictions like
physical distancing masks for several
more years
it's likely that there won't be enough
vaccines for the population
as as the vaccine rolls out
a sobering statement from canada's chief
public health officers as a number of
vaccines show significant promise in
stage three of development
and dr teresa tam followed that up with
another dose of reality
we're planning as a public health
community that we're going to have to
manage this pandemic
certainly over the next year but
certainly maybe in a planning for the
longer term or the next two to three
years
not what weary canadians want to hear as
they long for a sense of normal to
return
be it patios or restaurants fully
reopening
complacency is probably one of our most
dangerous aspects to to our
management of the virus and to our
response
that's why physical distancing and
wearing a mask will continue
to be important to prevent the spread of
covid19
that advice hasn't changed in recent
weeks but alberta is changing its stance
on masks for school kids now saying it
will be mandatory for all children grade
four and up
when they head back this fall the
current evidence indicates that the
older a child
is the more similar their transmission
may be to adults
and that's again the reason why we've
had the grade four as this cut off
health officials say wearing masks and
other safety measures need to be seen
as layers of protection to help contain
a virus
we're still learning about the kovid 19
alert app is supposed to be another
layer
but it also appears to have limitations
some phones are too old and cannot adopt
this app
and ironically the people who are most
likely to need it
cannot access it so it's incumbent upon
the app developers to find a solution
dr teresa tam echoed that sentiment but
still hopes as many people as possible
will download it
to help increase its success saying it's
one of many tools public health
officials are using
in the fight against covet 19. mike
lacouter global news ottawa
and you can find more on canada's
long-term plans including back to school
on our website some parents are forming
pandemic pods in order to keep
homeschooling their kids that's at
globalnews.ca
global national the american president
has
further complicated questions about the
chinese-owned app
tick-tock donald trump who said he might
ban tick-tock
now says the u.s treasury should get a
cut if an american firm
takes over the app the chinese
government is not happy about his
threats
an editorial in the state-backed website
china daily called the plan a
smash and grab and said the country will
by no means
accept the theft of a chinese technology
company
president trump threatened first that
he'd shut down tick tock in the u.s then
offered a 45-day reprieve to allow
microsoft to purchase the app from its
chinese parent company
the trump administration is concerned
about chinese authorities accessing data
of tick tock users
something the company denies
on the american east coast tonight
tropical storm issa east continues to
pack a huge punch
it made landfall in north carolina's
coastline is a hurricane and it's since
been downgraded
but the storm has spawned tornadoes
it has now moved through philadelphia
dumping heavy rain and winds of over 100
kilometers an hour
that downed trees and power lines and
caused storm surges
four people have been killed and there
are fears that number could rise
one tornado hit this mobile home park in
north carolina
and there are also reports of tornadoes
in new jersey and delaware
in south korea monsoon rains have
drenched that country for 42 days now
the longest spell
in seven years
that's caused flooding that's forced a
thousand people to flee their homes
and at least 14 people have been killed
including three members of the same
family from new zealand
a woman her daughter and her
three-year-old grandson were found dead
after a landslide hit vacation homes
near seoul
overhauling the approach to treating
obesity coming up the updated guidelines
that go way beyond counting calories
plus cd mystery the unusual mail turning
up
across canada and around the world also
washed up on a desert island the
survival story of three
stranded sailors
there's a big change coming to the way
doctors in this country diagnose and
treat obesity
and experts in the field say it's about
time
new guidelines published today in the
canadian medical association journal
reflect
substantial advances in the assessment
and treatment of obesity
and shift the focus toward improving
health outcomes rather than weight loss
alone
it's much more complex than just
counting calories and getting more
exercise
experts say obesity is a complex chronic
disease
and as mike derlay explains the sooner
that's recognized the more people
can be helped what's the best way to
reduce
eat plenty or starve yourself for as
long as we've had ads
weight loss miracles have appeared to be
just a pill away
and these yummy low-carb baths sad diets
have come and gone
yet chronic obesity rates are rising
what we've done
up until this point hasn't worked we've
tried and tried and tried for years
to shame and blame people into losing
weight ian patton is one of those people
before undergoing bariatric surgery six
years ago his heaviest weight was 360
pounds
counting calories and dieting didn't
work for him
and as someone who is researching
obesity for his phd
he knew what he was talking about so um
it was a bit
weird for me because as i was going
through and doing my phd and
you know going to conferences and stuff
and talking
you know trying to lecture about obesity
i was standing there at my
absolute biggest and sickest until now
the canadian guidelines have had doctors
using bmi or body mass index
as a way to calculate obesity except bmi
is deeply flawed because it only takes
into account height and weight
ignoring everything that makes us unique
like muscle mass
race and sex for me to be considered
healthy on the bmi scale
i'd have to lose 80 to 100 pounds the
new guidelines completely rethink how we
address obesity
counting calories has been replaced by a
more detailed medical approach
there are now three pillars to treat
obesity weight loss medication
bariatric surgery and cognitive
behavioral therapy
which addresses the reasons behind a
patient's weight gain
they're also declaring obesity a chronic
relapsing disease
which the canadian government has so far
refused to do
and is critical for the way it's treated
any approach to obesity has to be a
long-term approach in the same way that
you know chronic other chronic diseases
have to have long-term approaches so
there are no quick fixes
and hopefully the guidelines are going
to get more people to realize this
and ultimately get more canadians the
medical help they need
mike drolight global news toronto
cd deliveries rooting out the mystery of
these unsolicited packages
those packages of mysterious seeds
people in countries around the world
including canada
the us and the uk have received in the
mail are
still a mystery they're arriving
unsolicited in people's mailboxes
most appear to be from china in packages
that are mislabeled
a u.s federal agency has identified some
of the seeds as a mix of ornamental
fruit and vegetable and herb and weed
species but they warn
no one should plant them as sarah
mcdonald reports
no one knows who is sending them or why
there's something seedy cropping up in
mailboxes
across north america there's like little
grass seeds
in there and nobody seems to know
exactly what's behind
the unrelenting unsolicited deliveries
landing on the doorsteps of thousands of
unsuspecting people
like natalie dempsey of alberta i didn't
know where it came from specifically and
i thought it was very
suspicious very odd it's odd and highly
suspect to
officials on both sides of the border
too with almost every province
and most states reporting residents
receiving packages containing
mystery seeds the small packets may look
harmless
but experts warn this could be a scam
or invasive species we're not at the
point that we can confirm anything
yet of course we are concerned the
canadian food inspection agency is
urging citizens who receive unauthorized
shipments
like this to report it to their regional
office
and while federal officials won't
elaborate on the suspected origin of the
packets
the u.s food and drug administration
says most south of the border
appear to be coming from china if you
find yourself on the receiving end of
suspicious seeds
don't handle them don't dispose of or
compost them and
most importantly don't plant them
they're a high risk species for us
because we don't know what they're there
and we from what we've seen they're
actually quite a variety of seeds that
have come in
as scientists work to dig up not only
what the seeds consist
of but any substance they could be
coated with
officials are investigating the intent
of the senders
this is the package it says it has
jewelry who often deceive customs
officials
and recipients through mislabeling
potentially malicious deliveries
as everyday items to have these mystery
seeds being sent
out who knows a little bizarre with the
seeds that should never sprout
already planting lingering questions
sarah mcdonald global news vancouver
next the prehistoric patient behind the
world's oldest known case of cancer
this story of survival sounds like the
stuff of fiction
three sailors have been found after they
were marooned on a tiny remote island in
the pacific ocean
the men were spotted because they wrote
a giant
sos on a sandy beach military aircraft
from the us and australia had been
searching for them and spotted it
they were stranded on a tiny island in
micronesia for three days after their
seven meter skiff ran out of fuel and
drifted way off course the australian
defense forces dropped off food and
water for the men
and a micronesian patrol boat is coming
to get them
in an historic or you could say
prehistoric first
a dinosaur has been diagnosed with
cancer a team of canadian researchers
found evidence of bone cancer on a 76
million year old fossil
it's the same type of cancer that still
affects some people today especially
children
and young adults heather urix west
explains
osteosarcoma was the cancer that
inspired terry fox to run his marathon
of hope
the aggressive bone cancer also
ultimately cost him his life
these cancers are most common in
adolescents and young adults
they occur most commonly in the second
decade of life young adults are at an
increased risk of this cancer because of
how quickly their bones
grow it's something they have in common
with these
prehistoric beasts dinosaurs had to grow
a lot to reach full size and now
canadian scientists have
proof these animals suffered from
osteosarcomas
as well this bone was discovered more
than 25 years ago and it was actually
in storage in the royal tyrell museum
which is located in drumheller alberta
the bone's unusual appearance was first
thought to be because of a break but
after
ct scans and a microscopic examination
the world's first dinosaur cancer
diagnosis was made
the aggressive osteosarcoma tumor was
believed to be present throughout much
of the bone
the lower leg bone belonged to a
centrosaurus a horned dinosaur that
lived in what is now southern alberta
76 million years ago it would have
likely been
a fair bit of pain it would probably
been able to move around but not
at its full speed like normal and it's
possible that
it would have spread to other organs by
that point cancer isn't what killed the
animal
researchers believe it drowned along
with hundreds of other members of its
herd
but knowing the centrosaurus had cancer
shows us this disease
has been a part of life and death for a
very long time
one of the things that makes it so
difficult to battle is the fact that
at the core of it it's written into the
cell biology and the cell by
the cell life cycle and that's part of
what makes it so ancient but also
perhaps so difficult to
overcome in the decades since terry
fox's run
treatment advances have meant people
with osteosarcoma today
face a 70 to 80 percent chance of
surviving more than five
years likely much better odds than a
centrosaurus would have had
heather eurix west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's york
canada is the research ship
gnomeo docked in gimli on lake winnipeg
in manitoba
we'd love to see your canada please
email it to us and thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves
[Music]
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
you